Merry Christmas forget about the cost of
living crisis forget about the wars
forget about the grinding poverty
centralization surveillance and
censorship have a McDonald's or a Coke
or an Amazon product that'll cheer you
up
a nice Coke on Christmas six million
Awakening wonders thanks for joining me
on this Voyage towards truth and freedom
happy Christmas one happy Christmas
oh [ __ ] her on if it appears in a sense
festivals have always been a time of
universal distraction what is the point
of the carnival the point of the
carnival is to sedate and distract the
poor a temporary destruction to the
order of things I think to an extent
he's correct but you know I think that
they I don't even know where these
things I would love to know the true
roots of where General festivals came
into play but I can see some king and
queen or sitting in a Royal Court in one
of their let's charge them twelve
dollars a ride one of their advisors you
know in some old ancient court is like
throw a carnival for the people that
will distract them and make them happy
for a minute when they start complaining
about things and I could totally see
that being the case I want to see where
he goes with this but this in particular
a lot of the things that we're doing
Christmas is about Jesus well it's it's
lost its meaning to a lot of people but
the reason it started the reason it
started was for a really good reason
does it now just become a business and
is it just about money yes okay let's
have a look at some Christmas propaganda
well giving you some Christmas for
example more than one million poor
people with health problems in England
are at risk of cold at a time where
energy Giants are making huge profits
about 13 of New Yorkers are 2.7 million
people in the State live in poverty and
Rich Americans live for 15 years longer
than the poor
Merry Christmas now let's have a look at
the old propaganda Factory and their
disgusting celebrated lauded
advertisements that we have piped into
our brains at this time of year to keep
us dumb stupid gleeful and distracted
I love him as soon as you hear that
piano you know that the bullshit's on
its way
list
a list
yes I think I will make a list how about
energy companies start giving some of
their profits back how about Pfizer give
some of their profits back how about
companies that sell sugary salty
disgusting food aren't given platforms
like this no you're going on the naughty
list
[Music]
a lot of times can you hear a cover song
Something Like This
but I'm sick and tired of that whole
month I couldn't agree more rendering of
a time I am so sick of every commercial
that's like trying to go deep oh it's so
annoying so but it's such [ __ ] and
it's so overused
[Music]
the thing is is it works as well isn't
it you sort of start to feel it like sad
and lonely it's actually [ __ ] working
it's actually [ __ ] working
it's crazy how just putting a song on a
video emotional pornography you can have
such an effect on how you perceive it
yeah not bloody helping but if you sit
and watch it your body will respond and
this is what this is it titillates you
and stimulates you in ways that you
evolved oh my God that cute kid is more
difficult to sort of go okay inflation
is it a 40 year High 2 million UK
households are behind on bill payments
Millions face poverty in the US AS
Global food companies paid out nearly 15
billion to shareholders the world's
biggest food giants made 20 billion in
profits while warning of high prices to
come now you can't hold that information
in your head while you're looking at
some cute little kid doing something
cute and they know that about us they
know that we are sweet they know that we
are decent they know that love is the
Ultimate Reality and they use that to
make money
[Music]
it's not gonna be easy because male and
postal workers are on strike because
they're egregiously underpaid and
vilified by the mainstream media
this is the Grinch
[Music]
go to McDonald's
oh my God
there's no way because all it's doing is
trying to arouse a sort of morkish
deracinated ungrounded unrooted
sentimentality and then it's time he
goes that was a McDonald's well
McDonald's McDonald's you're miserable
and you lost your list and Christmas is
ruined so go to McDonald's that's how
they trick little kids though because I
remember when they were when you were
little it's like go to McDonald's it's
like such a treat that's how they shove
it down your throat when you're little
yeah it was 194.7 billion they're gross
profits in 21 to 22 was 13 billion
during these various Wars what is
Russell Brand is he like a he's an actor
and a comedian no but like what now he's
a now he's a political but is he just an
independent thinker or just it seems
like he's like he doesn't like companies
making money which I mean I agree with
him on like the Pfizer [ __ ] all of them
he doesn't I don't know I haven't seen
enough of him to know but I don't think
that he yeah I don't think that he lies
with one thing
like he's anti-capitalist but it also
seems like he's clear on the reality of
they're making records profits and or
they're making you know 15 billion was
paid out to shareholders on major food
companies meanwhile everyone is paying
between 10 and 30 percent more for food
and they can barely afford to keep the
lights on in their homes yeah it's crazy
like up yours I like to McDonald's food
are linked to health problems like
reproductive health problems so
ironically wouldn't be able to have a
cute little kid to say the Christmas
list because your nuts and ovaries won't
work because of the bloody McDonald's
will have a median sperm count of zero
so enjoy the last generation and enjoy
that Big Mac eating junk food raises the
risk of depression says a multi-country
study a study that found that foods
containing a lot of fat or sugar always
processed leads to inflammation not just
of the gut but the whole body known as
systemic inflammation so what they do
this isn't newer this isn't new
information affordable food that's bad I
read this stuff 20 over 20 years ago I
was reading this stuff and it's just now
starting to leak out into the mainstream
media back then it was they were just
debunked as junk studies that nobody
could trust the companies had more
control back then over what went into
the media but now with social media and
citizen journalism it's harder to hide
the underbelly is showing it's coming
Christmas which is going to be about
kindness and Christ and community and
transcending the material experience
they use the values of spirituality to
further inculcate materialism
ain't that some I don't think so I I
actually disagree with that because I
think that people that are used talking
about like in churches talking about
Christmas being about Christ they are
not also talking about materialism what
happens what happens with the companies
the companies are completely leaving
Jesus out of it they're trying to make
it about morality and kindness and
sweetness but there's about Jesus they
certainly leave Jesus do you mean am I
going to vomit then yes
I think I got it now we go all out with
the lights food we live for food I love
my mama's dumplings they ask for my
dolma I suppose this is an opportunity
to see how powerful and important
message is like inclusivity and
diversity and the celebration of
whatever culture is Meaningful to you is
utilized to promote you know and if you
haven't guessed it yet this is Walmart
cookies cupcakes and it has to be
different please because I'm not washing
dishes in a sense you can say that they
I don't like that [ __ ] when I'm at like
a Thanksgiving or somewhere and there's
paper plates no you were raised snotty
like me all the top hundred Revenue
generating entities in the world 71 of
them are corporations at number 10 is
Walmart so Walmart is economically
larger than Spain India and South Korea
so Walmart is not an insignificant
entity so what you're watching is not
only the propaganda for a commercial
product producing vendor but and it's
significant financial power that is able
to mold and influence your experience of
reality so what you're watching there
really is propaganda masquerading is a
bit of festive inclusivity it's not
marketing
is marketing is to grow business and
their influence
the distinction between what you're
presented is reality what you experience
is reality and the true nature of
reality what is organizing your planet
what principles are affecting your life
how is your experience of being a human
alive right now in this planet being
utilized rebooted and manipulated in
order to generate profit to reduce your
personal power and to distract you from
the fact that you can't prevent this
from happening I love this I love this I
love that he's trying to get people to
think differently about advertising I
used to remember when I was younger I
would see a commercial and I'm like oh
my God I love that commercial oh because
it made me feel it did its job and now
my feelings and now I see I see the
commercials the puppet Master's got to
me yeah the Puppet Masters and I just
think this is such a horseshit I look at
it just the way he is it's just oh I
know this is all just oh you're gonna
make me feel warm and fuzzy and then so
that I can then hopefully associate the
feelings I have for my family and my
traditions with Walmart no Walmart you
don't get to make me feel warm and fuzzy
you don't get the same status as my
family in my in my heart and in my life
[Music]
prominence because of entrepreneurial
Ingenuity but you the taxpayer are
funding poverty wages at organizations
like Walmart a government study shows
that taxpayers I didn't even think about
that salvation wages at McDonald's and
Walmart Walmart employees have to rely
on food stamps and Medicaid employing
the most workers whose income is
subsidized by taxpayers so ironically if
you worked at Walmart you won't be able
to how did they convince people to work
for minimum wage like how is that even a
DOT because what like when I pay people
it's you know I have to think like
what's worth people's time and it's like
how do you convince people they're going
and working for ten dollars an hour is
it just because it's like brainless work
well no it's not necessarily brainless
but it is entry level and you know you
get paid based on your your level of
experience and skill in life and true
level work is entry level work you get
what you deserve you don't want to work
at minimum wage don't do a minimum wage
job do it gain some skills grow and
continue to climb but you can't you're
not going to climb in life by
complaining about anything I don't know
who said it but they said you get paid
based off of how big of the problem you
solve is so the bigger the problem you
solve the more you get paid if you're
stacking shelves at Walmart it's not a
very big problem yeah generally not
causing a ripple in the space-time
continuum
oh my God
you're being dragged face first into
idiocy by these organizations the truth
is that Nestle Mars and Hershey have
been using child life oh yeah cheap
cocoa a 2020 study by the University of
Chicago found that 1.5 million it is so
good that he's like showing this
different point of view this is not new
in high school when I was in high school
bazillion years ago we used to write
letters but Amnesty International we
wrote physical letters and had to stamp
them and mail them and Amnesty
International and they would they was
were an organization that I honestly I
don't even know if they still exist I
haven't heard of them in a while where
you try to write to our Congress people
to help them fight child labor in
countries around the world and now so
this isn't new and him putting it out
there is helping to you know get get it
in front of more people the internet's
helping to get in front of more people
but it doesn't stop people from buying
cheap [ __ ] everybody loves to go to the
dollar store and buy things for a dollar
doesn't matter that it was made with
child labor our government is doing it
companies are doing it and we're
participating in it and then screaming
about [ __ ] like pronouns were like
wearing clothes that were made by slaves
it's disgusting it's crazy today with
the main countries for production being
the Ivory Coast and Ghana on one hand we
have dancing celebrating children and on
the other hand we have children toiling
in Cocoa plantations being paid what
amounts of slave wages
[Music]
well it just transitions back to oh my
God
contain toxic heavy metals
you can't what is this [ __ ] now you
can't know any of this and then still
consume the same and if you do you're
sticking your head in the sand and
you're an [ __ ] ignorance is bliss it
is
what is this take a guess take a guess
just take a guess uh a technology
commercial for so she can face time with
her grandma in the city okay
[Music]
I'm the father I've got daughters part
of me foods that life should be like
this I should be sort of in a tool shed
sort of doing something while my kid
does a handstand but like is your life
like that my life isn't like that and
part of the reason my life's not like
that is because all authenticity in
reality is being eroded in order for us
to live in a kind of bizarre Matrix
simulacrum where we don't have access to
real feelings or real Community anymore
everything is commodified well
continually and it seems impossible to
use the great tools that technology and
science have granted us to create a
better fairer and more authentic so
Beast so best Soul Beast yeah you eat
poison you go to your nine to five you
get home you stare at your phone and
distractions all day on the weekend
you're tired on Saturday you get drunk
with the boys on Friday so you're
hungover and then Sunday it's football
and then you're back in the cycle and in
between all that you watch a million
commercials that make you and you stare
at your phone and wish you had a life
that you don't have it's crazy like when
you stare at your phone you just you
don't have any thoughts you just like
consume content and it's just for next
thing next thing yeah and it's just it's
just like mind emptying because like
every single second of the day your mind
is doing something and you it's just
you're just you're always distracting it
with something you can distract it with
good stuff where you're gaining value or
[ __ ] or you're just killing time to
your death you're continually distracted
and your attention is placed into
mind-numbing commodity I say that I say
that but people don't I say it's
mind-numbing I say it's mind-numbing
like when you bring this to people's
attention though they they just they
they go oh no not me oh no not me no
that's a no I know I know you know it's
like no no I at least acknowledge that I
do it too like I I get caught on Tick
Tock and at least I know I'm like being
a dumbass that's something people refuse
to even acknowledge it and then they
push it aside and they they just go
about like they don't want to expand
their minds people and this goes with so
many things people don't want to
actually learn something new or consider
something about themselves or learn a
new pers you know a new way to look at
things
commodity like this one and they know
that and they count on that and they
make money based on that what is it
Coca-Cola
but if you actually work for Amazon you
haven't got time Amazon or off or have a
piss is there a reality
[Music]
so this is Amazon Amazon is essentially
now a nation a massive onto the planet
and like listen I'm not some Crusader I
use Amazon how can you not
CH their TV show I'm not sort of
Crusader point I'm making it's so
immersive and total it is like we are in
that snow globe like we live in that
[ __ ] thing now
[Laughter]
Community activity Amazon's gross profit
in 2021 pandemic was 216 billion nearly
a 15 increase from the previous year for
some organizations the pandemic was
positive Amazon gets 10 billion dollars
of federal contracts despite Biden's
Union pledge the Biden Administration
has re-awarded a massive 10 billion
Federal contract to Amazon even as the
president faced Mountain pressure to
fulfill his promise to Halt such
contracts to companies that refused to
remain he has broken every single
promise he has made
what was the stuff about Amazon and
unions what was the stuff about that I
did the employees were trying to
unionize they truly don't know
everything about how do they get around
them doing that they did something smart
we have to look into it I'm not really
sure I do know that when Union Advocates
are trying to get employees to unionize
and Lobby that companies also have
lobbyists and uh information that goes
to employees anti-union information so
I'm sure that that's a little part of it
so they use values like family and unity
business they break down solidarity they
break down the possibility of fairness
and justice
[Music]
while Amazon presents the public facing
side of its businesses saccharing family
orientated and fun the reality is they
have an 80 High rate of serious injury
their workers a union-backed study of
safety data found Amazon workers had 5.9
serious injuries per hundred people
almost eight percent higher than the
rest of them oh my God the studies
organizers blamed Amazon's obsession
with speed as the main cause of its
problems
wow wow
anyway like sort of the Ingenuity of the
copyrighters and creators of this advert
is sort of like has to be acknowledged
but what could be happening six percent
of employees are getting injured like
that's a high number I know what's going
on in there like Fireballs shooting
around where they got a Dodge prayer
belts is it jumping on and off of trucks
is it picking lifting trying to lift
packages really quickly that are heavy
without proper uh you know equipment
interesting and who knows what's here
like who also knows the the depth of
those articles doesn't surprise me
Amazon treated amazing in order to
better present a an organization that's
essentially more powerful than the
Journey of the Earth's Nations as a sort
of a benevolent entity is a perfect
snapshot into the place we've arrived at
in this world almost unable to discern
reality unable to assess while there is
such egregious poverty unable to
understand why there are ongoing Wars
because we are ultimately being invited
to live in a synthetic version of
reality where our true emotions are
stimulated in order to serve of
corporate goals that's what's happening
in that advertisement you're watching
something that's authentic and real and
pulls at your heartstrings but if those
values were truly held dear by the
organization they simply wouldn't behave
in the way that they do so you are
really living in a synthetic reality
your hormones dopamine serotonin being
stimulated while you're being fed bad
food using dubious Services living
ultimately in an undemocratic world that
has no real values or principles just
the appearance and performance of those
values
foreign
[Music]
perhaps the biggest irony of all is that
if those corporations lived by the
values they espouse in those commercials
they wouldn't be able to afford to make
those commercials it's a living
contradiction or Paradox or perhaps most
of all beautifully presented disgusting
hypocrisy
[Music]
all right yeah great who cares so he
made so he's absolutely right because if
you think about how to treat how they
treat you know we were talking about the
candy companies the food companies you
know one of them feeding out 15 billion
in profits while while Americans are
having a hard time filling up their
kitchen cabinets would you ever do that
to a person face to face like just sit
and watch somebody be hungry over food
when you can actually cut some of that
pain away and they do this from an ivory
Tower because they say that they care
and these are their values but they're
not but they don't it is all marketing
even their even their mission statements
and their value statements are marketing
they're all rug pulls it's so they have
external mission statements that they
talk to their their you know their
public audience with where they tell you
oh yeah we're all about diversity and
we're all about love and giving to the
community and this and that and then
they have their internal ones you've
never worked at a major corporation but
they have internal corporate values
really for the employees and because the
employees are customers too in a sense
like you have to be convinced that
you're part of something important and
big so that you'll work hard so they
just it's just this constant
manipulation and the more we can look at
marketing whether we're being marketed
internally at a company or being
marketed you know on all these
commercials we really have to be much
pickier and choosier choosier about
where we spend our money and where we
put it because it's crazy though because
we're putting a monopoly that it's like
what do you how do you just not use
Amazon right well you can it just
requires a lot of a lot of sacrifice a
lot of you know doing without things and
doing without conveniences so it's hard
it's really hard it's really hard
they're using the things that are
important to distract you from the
things that are important or more
importantly to distract you from the
fact that those very things are being
lost the world that they present to you
is the world we should be living in but
we cannot live in that world as long as
we grant them the kind of undemocratic
global power that they have these things
are not unconnected from a surveillance
state from a sensorial planet from a
globalist agenda where you will own
nothing and be happy because what you're
being presented is the appearance of
values while real values are swept aside
in favor of the only value that they
truly prize centralized power
centralized profit and Democratic
ability to pursue your agenda without
disruption or Interruption from the
ordinary all right well I can't say
enough about how how much I enjoyed that
and Russell Brand is still right on
point we have to we have to be more
conscious about what kind of companies
we're using okay well we're going to
leave now and we're going to go have
Christmas dinner with our family we have
a big Italian traditions and we're
really excited about that Sonny's going
to put on a button-down shirt he's going
to get out of his real talk uniform yeah
I haven't taken this shirt off in years
all right guys Merry Christmas to all
who celebrate and thank you for watching
have a good one Merry Christmas
and
[Music]
[Music]